i want to ask you guys about a very
important story um there's a teacher
that's being arrested because she made
[ __ ] muffins
yeah
now i'm assuming that the both of you
have
ingested probably billions of sperm in
your lungs yeah
no one load of it
is billions oh really yeah so you
probably no comment trillions
like so like between the two of you it's
possible what's after trillions
begillions
gazillions gazillions
gazelles
no so between the two now that's just by
proxy of how many sperm are in a load
okay
right is that a big deal that there were
some common muffins
that's pretty uh not okay yeah
it's not okay but are you also like get
over it like that whatever like no if
someone fed
someone unwillingly sperm that is like
death penalty that is horrible
now have you ever had a guy not tell you
and then
came in your mouth no no no no this is
not i no i'm the girl that's lying on my
back i'm this is not nobody's no you
want to get skull [ __ ] but
you've never had a yeah but like
a guy [ __ ] you go i'm going to come
what
what yeah what is right you can't just
come and like anywhere you want without
warning that's absurd i can't help it if
my dick is smashing into your tonsils
i have to help it what
no i there's no just like surprise come
in my life
do you
share this sentiment towards surprise
come and look every come a surprise
[Laughter]
i would just like um someone to honk the
horn so even
so i can just prepare my tonsils that's
all i want
yeah that's mine if you just about just
look at me
through my
uvula i just need you to honk the horn
what's a uvula
the thing that moves when you
do that i thought that was tonsils
wait actually that's a uvula yeah the
dangly thing in the background you think
they take out that thing i thought
they'd take that out the thing's on the
side of that i did not know that what i
thought that that was tonsils
thought that was tonsils
the thing in the back of the throat you
thought that was two things yeah
i thought it was tonsils but it's only
one thing yeah why is it like a rhodes
scholar
like i thought it's just tonsils
like not multiple it's just like that's
a tongue pants is one pair of pants
yeah i see yeah but i wouldn't even call
it a pair of pants
i just thought that's a tonsils
[Laughter]
honestly i've asked girls do you not
have tonsils like that that's crazy
where were we
you girls were talking about ingesting
calm i was trying to make a more
you know biology lesson here i'm just
shocked that like surprise come is
acceptable to everyone except like i to
me that's like do you like me if you're
like
surprising me esther can i ask you a
question yes
is it that much of a surprise
like you know it's at the end of this
journey right
again honk the horn i've just never had
i've never had that be a surprise but it
what is it maybe i'm not sex i don't
know i just don't know i mean it's maybe
the polite thing to do but i don't know
if it's necessarily that rude like
we we all know what's going on here it's
like if you're in the river looking for
gold and then some gold gets into the
pan you're not like well why didn't
anybody tell me
right you're digging for the gold and
then it's there i [ __ ] and gold are not
things that i usually comp together but
i i hear you i hear you
i think they can be comparable
[Laughter]
you know depending depending on the [ __ ]
i mean the right person comes in you
there's some gold so if you ate one of
those [ __ ] lace cupcakes yeah you would
be like no big deal it was just a hair
it would be like equivalent of having
like a hair honestly yeah no are you
serious no it would be the equivalent
but he sends hair back immediately and
gets mad no i don't care about hair no
you don't care about her
anything i eat anything you just take a
[ __ ] he picks the hair up with his hands
and then place it on the side
what if you find a sperm in your food
you're not gonna send it back a singular
sperm yeah you pull it out you go what
is this okay i'll do one better when i
first started jerking off i didn't know
if i was coming or not and then i would
just pee and then i'd like put my finger
in front of the stream and then i'd
taste it to see if i was oh if i was
peeing or coming i respect that i want
to know what the difference you're a
scientist thank you
dr schultz i'm dr schulz
and i had to figure out i was like i can
i know the flavor of pee so if i taste
this how do you know the flavor of pea
that's probably similar to what it
smells like
right so and then if it tastes way
different then that's probably come
and then i actually came for the first
time i was like oh no that's not pee
like i actually felt it i think that's
done you are weird bro why
i'm a young kid dude like coming back
from school just sitting on the toilet
taking a [ __ ] and then doing two days
vaseline pumpkin in yourself
crazy you know because it's in the news
i'll share this i had my first orgasm to
the pam anderson and tommy lee porn i
watched it on my ipod video
and i just thought i would that was your
first ever orgasm in your life yes
oh oh oh not the new
hulu series
the actual like old school one i
downloaded it on my parents mac and i
uploaded it to my ipod video and i
watched it and i was like because i had
been having sex yeah and i was in that
period of like i think a girl's life
where it's like am i having one i don't
know and then it wasn't until i watched
that point i was like we did it and and
you were delivering this orgasm to
yourself that's right okay now is your
first time ever trying yeah uh
maybe i don't know that's the thing
sometimes you try and it doesn't go
there yeah sex didn't do it before that
but then i learned it on my own that's
kind of the thing for women i hear
though yeah it's like you have to learn
your own body first
and then you can orgasm easier with guys
yeah or whoever true true very true